retrouve gulliver craag gulliver à kiev
gulliver bonsoir la situation s'est donc
aggravé selon le gouverneur de la région
de lougansk les ukrainiens recul après
avoir gagné du terrain à ses rivaux
donetsk oui il est un commandant
responsable de l'une des unités qui
combat actuellement à ses bureaux
donetsk qui a donné une interview à une
radio ukrainienne ce matin et qui disait
ça n'a vraiment pas de sens d'exprimer
en termes de pourcentage qui contrôle
plus de la ville les ukrainiennes ont eu
des contre offensif qui se sont soldées
par un succès dans certains quartiers
tcp redonnaise que toujours selon ce
commandant mais dans d'autres quartiers
de la ville c'est plus difficile c'est
vraiment une bataille dans le centre de
cette ville des combats urbains où c'est
vraiment bloc par bloc quartier par
quartier et les différentes parties de
la ville change de main tout le temps
c'est vraiment toutes les heures que la
situation change alors je pense que l ai
pas vraiment possible en ce moment de
dire qui va gagner en tout cas les
ukrainiens tiennent toujours une partie
de severodonetsk et ils ont pris la
décision de ne pas battre en retraite de
ne pas céder cette ville il faut aussi
souligner que juste l'autre côté de la
rivière l'a6 vers ce qui donne est que
de servir donetsk il y a les sites
chance qui serait vraiment la dernière
ville
dans la région de lougansk à être
totalement contrôlée par l'ukraine est
en réalité le vrai prix stratégiquement
parle on se serait licite chance parce
qu'après entre les sites chose qu elle
reste du donbass la région de donetsk il
n'est plus dirigé hier à traverser le
loyer donc c'est un stratégique bien sûr
c'est une guerre d'usure on peut dire ça
aujourd'hui oui et les ukrainiens disent
que il tue une grande y ait une très
grande quantité de troupes russes il
faut souligner bien sûr qu'on ne peut
pas vérifier les informations qu'il
tonne il n'y a pas de journalistes sur
place assez bourdonnette que c'est trop
dangereux mais on peut dire que les
ukrainiens ont gagné un certain crédit
de crédibilité ces dernières semaines si
vous voulez parce que quand ils
perdaient il disait plus ou moins il
l'admettait dont la plupart des cas dont
le monde impression c'est que ce qu'ils
disent c'est assez proche de la vérité
est en tout cas officiellement ce que
disent les militaires ukrainien c'est
que les russes subissent des pertes très
très très importante mais n'arrêtent pas
d'amener plus de réserves et de renvoyer
encore plus d'hommes sur le front dans
ses vers d'honnête merci de les régler